hi
hi how's it going we were saying we're
saying that the marketing
for the show it's these billboards that
are going to be going up there's like
adam but like the in the show open the
animated opening like there's a little
atom that's like inside of his head like
like at a desk in his like cut off head
so that's going to be the billboard for
the show which we like that idea
it's weird yeah it's really cool it it's
a cool it's a it's really cool looking
i love it and the show is so cool
looking it is so awesome to watch
something so unique and different and
how work can really suck the light up
out of you it's pretty amazing and then
i was thinking back to the last time i
saw you you and i were in haiti for
artists for peace and justice when the
graduating class happened so it's good
to see right again oh wow yeah that was
amazing wow
a lot's gone on since then a lot a lot
in the world yeah yeah yeah and here you
are directing this incredible show what
intrigued you to tell the story
i just thought it was very
unique and strange and familiar and
weird and funny and relevant and all
these different things that just were
very evocative i thought it was a very
specific world that dan had created and
this idea of this work life sort of uh
cut off that we look at and if you could
cut yourself off from your memories for
a few hours a day what you would be like
it just was a fascinating concept to me
it was something i wanted to see
yeah and adam you are so brilliant with
this character the fact that you could
bring the two different worlds together
and uh you really owned it um what was
it like for you to bring this character
to life and are you good at clocking out
once you leave work do you know how to
do that
you know um
it was really challenging uh and that's
part of what was so fun about it it was
sort of the
i don't know the math problem of of
the character and and the innie and the
audi and i i think it was really
important to ben and
dan and i that it feel like one person
but different
different halves almost of of one person
i i wanted to have one of them have a
mustache and a limp but ben said no to
so we had to come up with more subtle
differences between the two uh
and uh and that was really really
fun and really challenging because we
were you know shooting the whole thing
at once uh uh over over a period of
months
uh
and you know as far as the balance
between work and life
it really depends on the role but you
know for this it was it all kind of felt
like when i was trying to bring as much
of myself to the
to the role uh as
as possible um while you know trying to
figure out the differences uh because
neither of the two halves of marker
are
that much like me but i think there's a
lot in my life that i that i could bring
to it um
you know physiologically your body feels
like it just had a long emotional day so
it's you're exhausted but your mind is
is
is still kind of going so
the uh the work-life balance on
severance was
was tricky but
kind of exhilarating yeah you kind of
learned from this character it sounds
like it really does
yeah yeah yeah yeah you're right yeah
and ben uh you're working with patricia
arquette i mean it seems like you guys
are working on a lot of projects
together i mean she's an icon she's a
legend what is it about her that you
absolutely love
um
she's
incredibly
uh
serious about her work but also really
has an amazing sense of humor
but a very substantial human being um
and i i just i think who she is as a
person is really what i like most about
her uh she's got a very
you know just a good heart and cares
about people and she brings that to the
set you know when you're with her on the
set she's
inclusive of the entire crew and the
process and
um
and then she's fearless as an actress
she just will take the chances and we'll
go there and we were trying to figure
out some stuff in this show for
everybody we're you know like it was
sort of like defining a tone and we
weren't sure what it was so she's
willing to try things and um you know
she's just one of those actors you also
just watch you know she could do nothing
and it's it's fascinating to watch yeah
i would never want to see her in a
breakout room let me tell you
that room is scary thank you so much to
both of you congratulations on the show
thank you